hola a todos soy lebron tengo un
acertijo matemático para ustedes cuál es
la posibilidad de que haga 10 tiros
libres seguidos y aquí está mi buen
amigo sal con la respuesta esa es una
buena pregunta a lebron y creo que la
respuesta te va a sorprender para esto
busque en tu historial cuál es tu
porcentaje de tiros libres y estás
alrededor del 75% que por cierto es
mucho mayor que mi porcentaje de tiros
libres y una manera interpretar esto es
si tenemos un millón de lebron james y
puedes imaginar una gran cantidad de
lebron james tirando tiros libres
digamos que esta línea representa a
todos los lebron james ejecutando su
primer tiro libre ya vemos esta línea
tiro libre número uno esperaríamos que
en promedio el 75% aceptarían su primer
tiro libre déjame dibujarlo aquí aquí
está aproximadamente la mitad aquí sería
25% aquí tenemos 75% entonces
esperaríamos que el 75% de ellos
aceptaría su primer tiro libre 75 por
ciento y también esperaríamos que el
otro 25% en promedio fallaría su primer
tiro libre ahora lo que nos interesa son
aquí
los que hacen sus tiros libres queremos
10 seguidos
entonces enfoquémonos en este 75% que
acierta en su primer tiro algunos de
este 25% podrían hacerte algunos tiros
libres ya no nos interesan por así
decirlo están fuera del juego vayamos al
tiro libre número 2 tiro libre número 2
qué porcentaje de aquellos de aquellos
lebron james que acertaron el primer
tiro qué porcentaje esperaríamos que
acertarán el segundo y vamos a suponer
que hayas o no hayas acertado en el
primero no tiene efectos sobre la
probabilidad de hacer el segundo que
ésta continúa siendo la probabilidad de
que los lebron james acepten un tiro
libre dado entonces esperaríamos que el
75% de estos libros james también
acertada en el segundo tiro vamos a
tomar el 75% de 75% aquí tenemos más o
menos la mitad aquí tenemos un cuarto
esto sería tres cuartos que es
exactamente 75% aquí lo tenemos
esto representa de aquellos que
aceptaron el primer tiro cuantos también
aceptaron el segundo tiro podemos decir
que es el porcentaje de los lebron james
que esperaríamos en promedio acertar a
los primeros dos tiros libres y esto es
entonces
esta longitud es 75% de 75%
aquí tenemos 75% de 75% y creo que ya
podemos empezar a ver un patrón que
aparece aquí vamos al tercer tiro libre
tiro libre número 3 así que qué
porcentaje de estos cuates van a acertar
el tercer tiro libre bueno 75% de ellos
van a acertar el tercer tiro así 75% de
ellos van a acertar el tercer tiro y
esto cuánto va a hacer esto va a ser 75%
de este número y este número es 75% de
75% y si seguimos así hasta el tiro
libre número 10 y creo que ya puedes ver
el patrón que aparece así que vámonos
hasta el tiro libre número 10 y no
estamos brincando bastantes pasos vamos
a obtener una pequeñísima fracción
conformada por esos 10 y esto va a ser
75% x 75% x 35% 10 veces 75%
multiplicado repetidamente 10
entonces lo que nos queda aquí va a ser
75% por 75 por ciento por déjame copiar
y pegar para que no nos tome tanto
tiempo vamos a copiar
digamos esto es por 4
otra vez pegamos por 6 luego le voy a
poner los signos de multiplicación otra
vez pegamos por 8
finalmente pegamos otra vez ahí está x
10 y vamos a poner el signo de
multiplicación por x por x así que esta
pequeña fracción que hacer todos los 10
tiros libres de estar dada por este
valor de aquí veamos 75 de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 75% multiplicado por sí mismo 10
veces ahora encontrar este valor me
tomaría muchísimo tiempo hacerlo a mano
o inclusive si lucía una calculadora
podría cometer un error afortunadamente
tenemos una operación matemática para
tomar multiplicaciones repetidamente y
eso es elevar a una potencia así que
esto lo podíamos expresar como 75% 75%
elevado a la décima potencia multiplicar
75% repetidamente 10 veces estas son la
misma expresión ahora
por ciento como su nombre lo dice por
ciento significa por cada 100 esta raíz
también aparece en palabras como
centavos centuria 100 años en una
centuria sin centavos en un dólar así
que como esto significa literalmente por
ciento aquí tendríamos 75 sobre 100
elevado a la 10 y esto hace lo mismo que
0.75 elevado a la décima potencia
saquemos la calculadora para ver cuánto
nos da entonces tenemos que es 0.75
elevado a la décima potencia y esto nos
da igual a punto 0 56 y simplemente voy
a redondear a centésimas así es que
redondeando a centésimas obtenemos punto
06 entonces esto va a ser igual a
aproximadamente aproximadamente igual a
0.06 redondeando a centésimas lo cual es
aproximadamente igual cuando redondeamos
a 6 por ciento de probabilidad de
acertar diez tiros consecutivos que
aunque hay un alto porcentaje para
acertar un tiro este no es un valor de
probabilidad alto es ligeramente mejor
que uno
en 20 intentos ahora lo que quiero hacer
para todos aquellos que están viendo
este vídeo es pensar en cómo obtener una
expresión general que aplique para
cualquiera que conozca su porcentaje de
aceptar un tiro libre y quieres saber la
problema de acertar diez tiros
consecutivos bueno creo que ya vimos un
patrón aquí entonces la probabilidad de
hacer pongamos en donde en es el número
de tiros libres la probabilidad de hacer
n tiros libres seguidos para cualquier
persona y no estamos pensando únicamente
en lebron va a ser igual al porcentaje
de tiros libres en el caso de lebron es
75% elevado al número de tiros libres
seguidos es decir a la n potencia
podrías quizás jugar con esta fórmula si
tu porcentaje de tiros libres es por
ejemplo 60 por ciento es decir 0.6 y
quieres saber la posibilidad de obtener
cinco tiros seguidos que sería elevarlo
a la quinta potencia y esto nos da
redondeando a nivel de centésimas 8 %
qué es esto con diferentes porcentajes
de tiros libres y variando el número de
tiros libres seguidos que intentas hacer